alors qui est cet homme can use qui sera
demain nommé directeur général du
canadien de montréal qui va travailler
que jeff gordon qui lui le vice
président affaires hockey elle rit coach
icaunais le connais bien vous avez joué
avec luis enrique ou bonsoir
bonsoir
vous avez joué avec lui can use comme
j'étais petit ma peau petit
ben oui j'ai depuis l'âge de 14 ans on a
joué deux ans au niveau baltanas ça mais
on a joué avec les lions du lac st-louis
dans la région d'ouest a vu le mal à
notre connaissance aux collations j'ai
quand même eu sa tête non on va mettre
des choses au clair d'abord les
québécois basques est renvoyé sur
twitter ce matin il ya des gens douanes
et utah québécois québécois là il parle
fera vous où il parle français dans vos
lui par les français devront
effectivement c'est un c'est un lieu qui
parle très bien français c'est surtout
un excellent mais c'est un document très
bien français j'ai côtoyé quelques
durant plusieurs années dans les arénas
et on peut le faire avec les gens qui
nous entoure est alors que c'est un lieu
qui s'expriment dévier la langue de
molière un agent de joueurs il est
important il travaille à boston en fête
bretonne le connais bien on peut passer
derrière que depuis le jour 1 c'est le
choix de gordon mieux un processus le
mans tout cas on y reviendra mais qu'est
ce que l'agent de joie peut venir
apporter aux canadiens
c'est au niveau des négociations je
pense que c'est un atout on est capable
de bien négocier deux c'est comme si
l'âge impasse dans le cas ennemis s'il
va amener avec lui c'est justement le
bagage se sont tous les trucs des
comparables avec les joies pressé
d'aller chercher le plus d'argent
possible pour ses clients mais là il va
être capable de contrer ça de ce côté
patronal si je peux m'exprimer ici près
capable de négocier les contraires ont
des joies aussi aux meilleurs tarifs
possibles alors ça amène à tous
commentaires stimulant expliquez-moi
comment vous voyez là dit action un peu
bicéphale à deux têtes parce que jeff
gordon sera son patron en fait les rares
chiffres moyens et vice président mais
on a dit non mais on va laisser à quai
news l'autonomie il a 2 go qui a
remplacé autrement dit il
effectivement même si c'est une
nouveauté à montréal parce qu'on ne
jamais vu ça avec les canadiens de
montréal ont le vidal porte avec
plusieurs équipes il y avait un vice
présidents exécutifs les opérations
hockey ou le directeur général vous
serez apporter à un patron qui connaît
alors qu' à montréal c'était pas que
julien la lgv est un monsieur monsoon
mais match bergeret l'époque devait se
rapporter à dire pour celle qui n'est
pas connaît là ok mais n'est ce n'est
pas un spécialiste
de la gestion de l'eau at il maintenant
on va d'abord travaillé
ils vont prendre des décisions a semblé
diamant et ceux qui pensent que caillou
c'est un yes men si vous me permettez
l'expression
quelqu'un qui dit oui à tous là on le
connaît vraiment pas bien son est
capable de 0,2 lui parce que c'est un
ultime challenge account parlez-moi des
autres qu'on avait envisagé brière
mathieu darche patrick roy est ce que
vous croyez que les gens viennent la
question est ce que dans le fond gurten
il connaissait ces seuils connaissait
bien yousfi savait que celle inclue me
mais c'est surtout quelqu'un vous savez
il y avait un pas en avant parce que
quand on veut travailler en équipe qu'on
veut créer une chimie pour betting
synergies aussi avec avec quelqu'un vous
savons prendre ses décisions dans
l'équipe pour revente et cette équipe le
canadien je sais qu'on impose qu'ils
m'ont vraiment aidé à montréal mais
c'est le cas car on était en deuxième on
peut pas les plus beaux seulement ali
plus haut alors au doute capable de
faire le travail rapidement et quand on
connaît quelqu'un mais c'est plus facile
de devenir mars il travaille bon piroi
dans le mode path un coin seconde langue
qui a été rencontré est-ce qu'il va se
retrouver entraîneur finalement
prochains mois on va tout avoir pour le
même prix
baisse on sait jamais je peux le secret
des dieux mais c'est ce que d'aucuns pas
pkoi avait la faveur du public c'est
super qu'ils laissent personne
indifférent on a aimé c'est d'avoir à
montréal mais se reposer qui a pâti qui
à un moment donné ne pourra pas se
retrouver derrière ben
ça serait pas la combinaison parfaite un
haricot roi est la france là derrière le
baiia le respect des joueurs le les deux
news et gordon qui vont chercher les
meilleurs joie qu'ils rebaptisent puis
monsieur molson qui regarde ça au piqué
d'image compte à
taper quelque chose qui a démonté ce qui
est bon avec des jeunes joueurs mais bon
pour développer des joueurs également il
faut croire que même si les joies aride
à la ligne cela il ya toujours l'aspect
développement des jeunes joie également
aussi alors qu'opera exceptionnelle à
montréal sur sections non and ariko vous
l'avez dit fort ah bah tiens ce club ça
ne peut pas aller plus mal
non effectivement on doit absolument
inventé je pense que la première chose
c'est qu'un petit ours doit faire on
arrivait avec le job pour tous qui
devait garder de tout les joueurs de
l'organisation à partir de cailloux
presse jusqu'au joie qu'on a repêché
lors du dernier repêchage on va devoir
régler le problème de nos gueules mario
là c'est le premier choix du canadien au
rial qui apporte qui a pas fait
l'unanimité
on veut d'abord à régler ce dossier leur
très très rapidement et il va assumer
dans un âne et moyennement rapprocher
quelle joie qu'on veut avoir dans la
formation de 2,3 ils sont n'est pas
capable de voir ses joueurs 6 2 3 1 dans
sa formation je pense qu'ils étaient
peut-être de libérer faire le ménage et
ça malheureusement à saint-puy également
qu'à l'est pas il va avoir de grosses de
6 à 8 h 15 oui parce qu'ils coûtent cher
bon très bien
enrico voyons chaque coach icaunais
merci beaucoup nous avons parlé au
revoir